[موسيقى]
من العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وقبل الاف
السنين نثر العرب شعرهم معلقات جزاء
[موسيقى]
امرؤ القيس الذي قال قفا نبكي من ذكرى
حبيب ومنزلي بسبط اللواء بين الدخول
فحنت ترى ابن شداد الذي صدح يوما قائلا
واختر لنفسك منزلا تعلو به او مد كريما
تحت ظل القسطلي هذه الابيات وغيرها ما
زالت الى اليوم شاهده على لغه الضاد
وعظمتها تحكي قصص العرب وايامهم وتنقل الى
الاجيال اللاحقه سيره اقوام مروا من هنا
هذه الارض التي تحتفي بالشعر العربي وتسمى
عام
عاما له
[موسيقى]
هنا من هذه الارض كان العرب يحتفون بلغتهم
وعلى امتداد تاريخهم كان الشعر العربي
المنطلق من الجزيره العربيه
الاكثر تاثيرا في تاريخ العرب الثقافي
والاكثر انتاجا لهذه الروائع الادبيه التي
ما زالت راسخه في الحضاره الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
اليوم ما زالت السعوديه تحتفي بشعر بدعم
كبير ورعايه لا مثيل لها من العاهل
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي
عهده الامير محمد بن سلمان دعم زاد من
مكانه الثقافه السعوديه عربيا ومنحها
القدره على الاعتزاز والاحتفاء بجذورها
الراسخه لتكون جزءا من تحقيق مستدفات رؤيه
2030 في ابراز الهويه الوطنيه والثقافيه
لصباح العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي الرياض